Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and NV
Energy
NV Energy the sponsors of this next
segment are helping their customers save
energy and money which is especially
important heading into the spring and
summer months
well it's important any time of year but
especially as we head into spring to
make sure that you are saving energy and
money when it comes to your energy bill
so we've called in an expert our friend
Adam Grant of Envy energy is here we're
about to head inside to a customer's
home to see a power shift bundle
appointment tell us what's about to go
on inside so the Powershell bundle
appointment is three three items we
offer a certified technician who comes
and does a full energy assessment of the
home they will install a smart
thermostat make sure it works it does
the best for the most efficient
opportunities for the homeowner and then
we'll also install direct install
materials which will start them on their
journey in other ways towards Energy
Efficiency well we have made our way
inside the home Adam tell us a little
bit about what's going on right behind
us here so you can see as our technician
is now doing these thermostat
installation so what he'll do is he'll
remove the thermostats that's currently
in the home put on a brand new smart
thermostat which can be controlled from
your phone it can be set for schedules
when you're in or out of the home and it
really saves about 120 a year on your
bill he will also then look at all the
other things in your house so look at
your appliances he will install Direct
install materials such as lighting and
or filters or he'll put a temperature
gauge inside your refrigerator and
freezer to make sure they're accurate
and then he'll wrap it all up by
providing you a report to the customer
shows everything that he did and it will
be all in one one location the customer
can learn how they can be more efficient
invite all the customers to come do it
sign up at nvenergy.com powershift So
Adam as the customer run me through that
process
you sign up for this and then take me
through after that so what the customer
can do is they have a couple options
they can either call us to one of our
energy advisors and then schedule their
appointment or they can go online at
powershift and theenergy.com powershift
and schedule the bundled appointment
which they'll be able to schedule at
their time frame whenever they want it
takes about 10-15 minutes to do and then
it will come out to have that on that
time techniques will come out
appointment takes about an hour hour and
a half and they'll be all set perfect
and as we head into a new season spring
and summer you know things are about to
get hot we want it cool inside I know
it's important year round but why
especially now is it important to make
sure you're up to date on all this stuff
well as we get into the hotter months
air conditioning gets used more so there
is more opportunity for more use of
energy so to have these energy efficient
opportunities to be more efficient to
have a thermostat that can control you
can control from your phone set when
you're away to make sure that your
lighting is all most efficient that
you're that your appliances are the most
efficient they can be will help you on
your bill as the summer comes into the
hot months and just last here even as
the technician walked in today he
mentioned he already noticed what you
know made this customer's Energy bill hi
so how is that for your customers to
know that they're getting you know all
those details before anything even goes
on they know what's going on in the home
so our technicians are great they will
look at your bill they'll look at the
opportunity we on our website there is a
a tool that shows you what appliances or
what part of your home is using the most
energy they reviewed that before they
came they have an idea of what they're
getting into to show the customer the
best way they can save based on their
personal home
thank you to NBN
B ending one of our Community Pride
Partners make your free Power shift
bundle appointment by calling
855-676-9373 or visit
nvenergy.com forward slash powershift
there's more Las Vegas now coming up
after the break we'll be right back